SECRETARY OF STATE MADELEINE
ALBRIGHT, THE FIRST WOMAN TO
SERVE AS THE NATION'S TOP
DIPLOMAT.
SHE WAS 84 YEARS OLD.
JOINING US ON THE PHONE RIGHT
NOW, THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BILL CLINTON.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
VERY SAD NEWS ABOUT MADELEINE
ALBRIGHT, A WOMAN YOU AND I KNEW
WELL.
YOU, OF COURSE, NAMED MADELEINE
ALBRIGHT FIRST AS AMBASSADOR OF
THE UNITED NATIONS DURING YOUR
FIRST TERM, THEN NOMINATED HER
TO BECOME THE FIRST WOMAN TO
SERVE AS SECRETARY OF STATE
DURING YOUR SECOND TERM.
HOW ARE YOU REMEMBERING HER AND
HER INCREDIBLE LEGACY TONIGHT.
>> WELL, I WAS GOING BACK OVER
MY LIFE WITH HER STARTING WITH
WHEN WE MET IN 1988, AND I LIKED
HER THE MINUTE I MET HER.
SHE WAS SO SMART, SO
WELL-INFORMED AND LEVELED
HEADED.
BY THE TIME WE STARTED TALKING
WHEN I WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, THAT WE HAD BOTH AN
OPPORTUNITY AND AN OBLIGATION
AFTER THE FALL OF THE BERLIN
WALL TO TRY TO FINALLY BUILD A
EUROPE THAT WAS FREE, PEACEFUL
AND DEMOCRATIC FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE NATION STATES ROSE ON
THE CONTINENT.
SHE WORKED FOR IT EVERY DAY AND
BELIEVED IN IT, AND SHE DID A
HELL OF A JOB AT THE U.N. AND
LATER AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> SHE CERTAINLY DID.
YOU SAY FEW LEADERS HAVE BEEN SO
PERFECTLY SUITED FOR THE TIMES
IN WHICH THEY SERVED.
THAT'S A DIRECT QUOTE.
HOW DID HER LIFE EXPERIENCE
PREPARE HER TO TAKE ON SOME OF
THE BIGGEST CRISES FACING THE
UNITED STATES AND THE WORLD?
>> FIRST OF ALL, SHE KNEW HOW TO
LIVE UNDER A CLOUD OF
UNCERTAINTY.
HER FAMILY HAD TO FLEE
CZECHOSLOVAKIA TWICE, ONCE
BECAUSE OF THE NAZIS AND ONCE
BECAUSE OF STALIN.
SHE DIDN'T LIKE EITHER OPTION
BECAUSE SHE KNEW THAT THE CZECHS
WANTED TO BE FREE TO CHART THEIR
OWN COURSE IN LIFE.
IT LEFT AN INDELIBLE IMPRESSION
ON HER.
THEY FINALLY CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES, HER DAD WAS A PROFESSOR
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF COLORADO.
MADELINE WOUND UP TEACHING AT MY
OLD ALMA MATER GEORGETOWN WHERE
I THINK ON AT LEAST TWO
OCCASIONS SHE WAS VOTED BY THE
STUDENTS AS THE MOST OUTSTANDING
FACULTY MEMBER.
BUT SHE WAS FAR MORE THAN AN
ACADEMIC, PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE
AGONIZING PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
SHE HAD BEEN THROUGH AS A CHILD,
AND SHE UNDERSTOOD CLEARLY THAT
THE PEOPLE CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE
BETWEEN GERMANY AND RUSSIA
DIDN'T WANT TO TRADE HITLER IN
FOR STALIN, THAT THEY WANTED TO
BE FREE TO CHART THEIR OWN
COURSE.
SHE PURSUED POLICIES THAT WERE
CONSISTENT WITH THAT, NOT ONLY
IN CENTRAL EUROPE BUT ALSO WHERE
WE WERE TRYING TO BRING
STABILITY AND OPPORTUNITY TO
PEOPLE IN LATIN AMERICA AND IN
ASIA.
SHE DIDN'T LIKE AUTHORITARIAN
DICTATORSHIPS, SHE DIDN'T LIKE
ARBITRARY VIOLENCE.
>> SECRETARY ALBRIGHT MET YOUR
WIFE HILLARY CLINTON THROUGH HER
WORK FOR THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND.
AND SAID SECRETARY CLINTON
WANTED TO GIVE A VOICE TO THOSE
WHO CAN'T SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
IT'S INTERESTING.
IT'S TWO WOMEN WHO BOTH SERVED
AS U.S. SECRETARY OF STATE.
HOW UNIQUE WAS THEIR
RELATIONSHIP?
>> THEY WERE ALWAYS TILL THE END
OF MADELINE'S LIFE, CLOSE
FRIENDS, ALMOST SOULMATES.
THEY AGREED ON NOT EVERYTHING
BUT ALMOST EVERYTHING, AND THEY
WORKED TOGETHER CLOSELY.
THEY TRIED TO SUPPORT EACH
OTHER, AND SHE WAS A REALLY
BRAVE AND STEADFAST SUPPORTER OF
HILLARY'S WHEN SHE RAN FOR
PRESIDENT BOTH TIMES.
BUT THEY ALSO DID A LOT OF
THINGS IN THE WORLD TOGETHER.
WHEN HILLARY WAS INVOLVED IN THE
IRISH PEACE PROCESS BY GETTING
PROT STAPT AND CATHOLIC WOMEN
TOGETHER AND WORKING FOR PEACE,
MADELINE WAS SUPPORTING THAT.
WHEN MADELINE WAS INVOLVED IN
DEMOCRATIC INITIATIVES AROUND
THE WORLD AFTER SHE LEFT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, HILLARY WAS
SUPPORTING HER.
THEY HAD A WONDERFUL
RELATIONSHIP.
>> THEY CERTAINLY DID.
I UNDERSTAND THE TWO OF YOU
ACTUALLY SPOKE, YOU AND
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT, RECENTLY AND
ACTUALLY DISCUSSED THE ISSUE OF
UKRAINE, THIS HORRIBLE WAR
THAT'S GOING ON.
CAN YOU SHARE WITH US WHAT THAT
CONVERSATION THAT YOU HAD WITH
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT WAS LIKE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I KNEW THAT SHE
HAD SOME HEALTH CHALLENGES, BUT
I TALKED TO HER TWO WEEKS AGO
AND SHE WAS IN STRONG VOICE AND
HER MIND WAS SHARP AS A TACK,
AND SHE WAS NOT ABOUT TO FOCUS
ON HOW LONG SHE HAD TO LIVE OR
DIDN'T HAVE TO LIVE BECAUSE SHE
KNEW SHE WAS GETTING GOOD CARE
AND SHE COULDN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT.
SHE SPENT THE ENTIRE
CONVERSATION TALKING ABOUT HOW
UKRAINE HAD TO BE DEFENDED AND
THAT WE HAD PUT THE LOT OF THOSE
AND MADE A MISTAKE THAT NATO,
SAYING WE'RE NOT GOING AFTER
NATO YET.
UKRAINIANS PROVED THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO BE PART OF RUSSIA, AND
THE IDEA THAT PUTIN WAS TRYING
TO SELL THE ARGUMENT THAT A
COUNTRY WITH A JEWISH PRESIDENT
WAS ACTUALLY A NAZI COUNTRY WAS
PATENTLY ABSURD.
SHE JUST WANTED TO SUPPORT
WHATEVER WE COULD DO TO BACK
UKRAINE.
THAT'S ALL SHE WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT.
SHE WAS HAPPY.
SHE WAS UPBEAT AND SHE DIDN'T
WANT TO VENTURE IN TO HER HEALTH
CHALLENGES.
SHE SAID I'M BEING TREATED.
I'M DOING THE BEST I CAN.
THE MAIN THING WE CAN ALL DO NOW
IS TO THINK ABOUT THE WORLD WE
WANT TO LEAVE FOR OUR KIDS.
>> I KNOW THAT MADELEINE
ALBRIGHT ONCE ATTENDED A
NATURALIZATION CEREMONY AND
REMARKED -- THIS QUOTE ALWAYS
STUCK OUT WITH ME WHEN SHE SAID,
AND I'M QUOTING HER NOW, ONLY IN
AMERICA COULD A REFUGEE FROM
CENTRAL EUROPE BECOME SECRETARY
OF STATE.
MR. PRESIDENT, HOW DOES THAT
RESONATE WITH YOU AS EUROPE IS
NOW FACING THE GREATEST REFUGEE
CRISIS SINCE WORLD WAR II?
>> WELL, I FEEL THE SAME WAY
MADELEINE DOES.
I THINK WE OWE IT TO THE
UKRAINIANS TO SUPPORT THEM.
THE BIGGEST UKRAINIAN DIASPORA
ARE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
CANADA AND THEY HAVE DONE VERY
WELL HERE.
I WENT -- A COUPLE WEEKS AGO I
WAS DOWN PLAYING GOLF WITH MY
FRIEND GOVERNOR McAULIFFE IN
FLORIDA.
WHEN WE CAME UP TO THE COURSE,
THE PERSON THAT GREETED ME WHEN
I GOT OUT WAS WAYNE GRETZKY,
MAYBE THE GREATEST HOCKEY PLAYER
IN HISTORY, A UKRAINIAN
CANADIAN.
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO HELP
THEM.
IF THEIR COUNTRY PREVAILS, AND
IN THE END I THINK THEY WILL IF
WE HANG TOUGH AND GIVE THEM THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED, THEN THEY'LL
WANT TO GO HOME.
IF IT DOESN'T WORK OUT, WE'LL BE
ENRICHED BY HAVING THEM IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WHEREVER ELSE
THEY CHOOSE TO GO.
THEY'RE INCREDIBLY GIFTED
PEOPLE.
AS WE SEE, THEY'RE VERY STRONG
WILLED AND RESOLUTE.
>> THEY ARE INDEED.
I KNOW MANY OF THEM MYSELF, AND
IT'S A HORRIBLE SITUATION GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
MR. PRESIDENT THANKS SO MUCH F